unilever naturelle paris sauf rennes
petits pains complets demi baguette
l'assortiment est classique le
présentoir un peu moins un coffre de
voiture utilisée comme boulangerie
ambulante
comme chaque matin depuis trois ans
marie barnier démarre sa tournée de
livraison de pain top départ pour une
matinée de travail et près de 65 km de
route pour se rendre chez tous ses
clients ça leur fait une petite
compagnie par longtemps mais voilà quoi
un service facturé 5 centimes plus cher
qu'en magasin payable à la semaine ou au
mois
s'il vous plaît vous dis merci monsieur
ça permet d'éviter de se déplacer
surtout ici faut aller vite pour trouver
une boulangerie à quelques kilomètres de
là la cadence ne faiblit pas chez ce
boulanger et ben tradition rendez-vous
s'est fait balancer les spéciaux car en
plus de la vente traditionnelle
il s'est lancé dans un genre nouveau
direction ce village doté d'un
distributeur de pain en automatique
trois fois par jour l'artisan vient le
ravitailler un sms l'informent du stock
restant on a développé tout ce qui est
boulangerie viennoiserie
donc les gens qui nous connaissaient pas
forcément grâce à la machine viennent
aussi en boulanger se pratique pas
besoin de s'arrêter à la plongée au pied
on peut avoir du pain trouvait à
l'origine du dispositif
le maire du village l'opportunité selon
lui de favoriser l'attractivité de sa
connerie la ruralité
tout le monde dit
on est délaissée il faut qu'on se prenne
par la main pour donner un certain
nombre de services aux gens ça crée des
rencontres
des liens sociaux dans le loiret d'eau
distributeurs similaires ont été
installés